i liken it to um seeing a parent with a
toddler like if you're at a restaurant
and the toddler is freaking out and
screaming
and there are the parents that give a
toddler what he wants and that's like
terrible
and white america when we when they see
these radicalized black people because
it's not all black people
but they get the attention right these
radicalized black people
screaming and wailing about something
they just give them what they want no
matter what it is defund the police okay
we'll just start talking about defining
the police because you've made that
ridiculous absurd demand that has never
been made ever
um and so i it's hard not to think that
this is actually the fault
of white guilt right this is this is
white guilt gone too far you guys are
like overdosing
on my guilt right now
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report i originally interviewed candace
owens on march
12th to discuss her new book blackout
but as we recorded
news of kovid related lockdowns began
and suddenly the news cycle totally
shifted
now six months later we're picking up
the conversation
and then releasing the original
conversation unedited
along with the new pickup we're doing
right now most guests would never allow
an interview to sit for so long but if i
can say one thing about candace owens
it's that she's a woman of her words
candace we
shot that interview it seems like a
lifetime ago but it was
march 12th and it basically was the day
that the lockdowns were beginning and
the second we stepped out of the studio
your assistant my whole team everyone's
telling us we're freaking out
you guys had to get out of la but you
were a woman
true to your word even now six months
later because you were like ah
i don't think this is anything this is
nonsense they're trying to take
trump out and from everything i know of
you since then you you have consistently
put that message out there
um so first off how are you i haven't
seen in a while how you doing
i'm doing well i think it's also
important that i break the story here
that on that day
uh the morning i woke up at my hotel i
had an allergic reaction
to a feathered pillow so my voice was
scratchy and i had a cold and i came in
and dave and his husband did not believe
that i had had an allergic reaction
and they thought i was covered 19.
it wasn't just that you had an allergic
reaction you came in you were coughing
and sneezing
the news is breaking all over the world
and and you were telling us that you had
blood that you were coughing blood
earlier in the morning
and then you're like oh you don't mind
if i work from your house all day do you
and what did i do what does a real
friend do you did
and we even fed you yes but that is what
feather pillows do to me i have the
strangest allergy with feathered pillows
and if i sleep on one i wake up and i
will literally be coughing blood but the
timing i will give you credit
it was just bad timing with all the
coven 19 stuff freaking out so
man how bad would would vox love it if
candace owens was patient zero
on covet 19 i mean come on they would
have loved it so much
they would have loved it all right so
listen i said to you before we did this
that i wanted to do a pickup with you
because it does feel like a totally
different world
in just six months it feels so different
but we are gonna air that interview
totally unedited just as it was um but i
thought it was worth talking for another
half hour so just about what has gone
on for the last six months if any of
that has changed your
your feelings on anything or anything
else so first off you you are
in dc uh you've become a creature of the
swamp somehow
um what's life like in dc how has covet
affected you and
and you know you're pretty outspoken
about this stuff but are
are you okay with any level of lockdowns
any level of masks anything
i'm not okay with any of it you know i
think it's very easy when people are
scared um to convince them to give up
their freedoms and we saw that i mean
people
hardcore conservative suddenly like yes
we should all be locked down
force businesses to close um and it's an
act of tremendous cowardice in my
opinion
for people not to realize that even in
times of a pandemic
we still have to have our basic freedoms
the freedom for if you are an individual
and you think that cobia 19 is the
bubonic plague you should have the
freedom to be able to decide to stay at
home
and lock yourself in a basement and
order you know seamless and instacart if
that's what you want to do but you
should also allow me to have the freedom
to open my business
and to say you'd like to come into my
business um you know i'd love to host
you here
um that's that freedom doesn't go away
because of a pandemic and i think people
sort of lost the threat on that because
they were so terrified
you know now people have obviously
shifted their opinions and people are on
my side i
tend to take a very bold and strong
opinion early on when people are unsure
um but to me it was the entire
coronavirus narrative was just too
perfect and too timely
in an election cycle we have to force we
have to shut down the economy
we have to put everybody on welfare and
give them stimulus checks
and you know nobody nobody can leave
their home so they have to rely on the
mainstream media narrative because they
can't go out and have experiences
with their friends that would make them
say you know what maybe um it's not
as scary as it is i've been out to a
party a few times and i haven't gotten
the illness so
i never trusted it of course i think
coronavirus is real
um what i was questioning was the idea
that it was some
plague-like thing that was going to take
us all out if we stepped outside of our
door and i really thought it was about
mail-in voting from day one
yeah and by the way you were taking it
from both sides you kind of touched on
this because you were you were giving it
to conservatives who were
all about a lockdown suddenly and and
you know government overreach let's say
and then i saw like the usual suspects
the lefty blue czech people
because you dared to go to whole foods
without a mask and then there were
several blue check people that
blood is on your hands candace how many
people have you killed
how many apparently tons for going to
whole foods they were like
how could she possibly say she goes to
whole foods every day
and i'm like look i can't go anywhere
because you shut down all of my events
i happen to live near a whole foods and
i like to look at what they have at the
meat counter every day
um so you know i at the you know at the
time during copic lockdowns i
was early in my pregnancy so um i
am an asthmatic so i have pre-existing
conditions and i ended up deciding to
travel the world uh because i was that
convinced of how untrue the narrative
was and i was shocked to discover
the second you step outside of america
you realize we're the only ones playing
the crazy game
when i was in england there were no mass
mandates i went to croatia they have no
idea that there's even
uh you know corona coronavirus going on
the kids are running around for really
no mass no social distancing
um so it just felt to me especially when
i got home because i had those
experiences that it was really being
manufactured
for americans all right so i want to ask
a question that i think
cuts to the heart of the candace owens
that i know but is also the
the the public candice owens which is
those first few days when
everyone was freaking out when everyone
was really freaking out and you just
took that position of this is bs this is
nonsense all of that stuff
what is it about you i've i've asked you
some version of this before because i
even remember seeing your tweets right
at the beginning and i was kind of like
oh candace like you might really be
stepping in it right now you know if a
week later
it turns out that you know half of us
have this thing or
everyone over 60 is dead but what is it
about you that you just
do it you you just get the thought and
you're just like
i'm rolling you know i think i have very
good gut instinct um i
i have i just always really trusted my
gut um on certain things and like i said
it was it was too perfect and usually if
something seems too perfect
it's because it's too perfect um and it
was just
also all of the media the death ticker
was very strange to me like that we've
never done that before i mean if
if cnn and msnbc did a death ticker for
every time there was a car accident
you'd be terrified to get in your car
so i was already seeing that there was a
psychological element that the media was
playing because there was
it was just very bizarre to see a death
ticker for anything of course you're way
more likely to get into your car and get
into an accident in la
but they would never do that um and and
so i really felt that it was just
too easy for them to get into the minds
of so many people and i'm so crazy about
not being brainwashed and
um it just and none of it made sense to
me at all it just it just from start to
finish never thought it made any sense
so so where do you think we're at with
it right now like do you think
trump should be doing more in terms of
forcing states to open
or should he just sit back and let them
all do what they want or
where are you at i think if i was the
president united states i
would do exactly what he did in terms of
sending it back down to state by state
sovereignty
um because it allows people to really
understand who's running their state
um depending on what state you're in you
know you're either
living in a communist state or you're
living with freedoms you're either
living with you know ron desantis or
gavin newsom
um and it's important people to
understand that their leaders are behind
this so that they can't just put it all
on the president but i do think
uh when he wins re-elect in november he
needs to he needs to put a stop to this
immediately
um and i i'm already seeing governors
saying that sort of a thing like rhonda
santa said he will not lock down the
state
what's what is predictable is that there
will be a second wave which is more
deadly
uh right about now so we're gonna start
seeing that in october and they're gonna
start ramping up that rhetoric
um and i think that you know at that
moment we need people to start standing
up and saying no and we're seeing that
in other countries uh
where you know they've they have been
fighting for their rights and we need to
see more of that in america because
you'll wake up one day you won't have
any and i i have not worn a mask so
i'm very proud of myself yeah and i
think it
it's public knowledge that you are
pregnant right i don't have to whisper
that
yes it is so you're also you're also six
months pregnant we're obviously
we're obviously thrilled for you but i i
know you're not going to do something
reckless
with your health or the health of your
baby you're doing what you think is
right
right exactly and you know my both of my
sisters happened to have their first
babies
uh two little boys uh in april so in the
middle of lockdowns i spent time with my
family
spend time with my grandfather who's the
most high risk you know type one
uh diabetic he's 75 blind he has seen
all of his family members during
coronavirus
um because even if you are an old person
you are at risk who is the government to
tell you what you're allowed to value at
the time that you have life
the time that you have left of your life
my grandfather values being with his
great grandchildren his grandchildren
um and his family you know he's law he
lost his wife uh
those people have lived through harder
times you know what i
people seeing mean struggle and you're
telling them they have to stay at home
it's such foolishness to not
let amer let each individual to make
their own decisions about their values
do you sometimes think that you're sort
of like a proxy for other people to live
out
the sort of boldness or something that
they want to live because like if i look
at what people tweet at you all the time
the p
you know a lot of people obviously say
mean things okay but the people that
like you
they're always sort of like oh i can't
say all this stuff in my life but like
candace just
just says it so something like corona i
think a lot of people are
are even right now really afraid to say
anything close to what you're saying
yeah you know they definitely have come
out i've gotten so many emails like i'm
so sorry i doubted you and now i see
how they're you know fluffing the
numbers or how none of it makes sense
and all these scandals are happening all
over
um and i hope that i hope that people
see me as a source of inspiration in
terms of just being yourself and being
audacious
um and you know uh you know to an extent
i know
when i first came out i'll never forget
the conversation with sam harris he was
like
uh and bless him but he was like
this is world war three like he was like
you all need to be in our bunkers you
all need to stay away this is the end of
the world
and you know head was just pounding me
with all of these facts and people that
he knew and
i think sometimes people can be so smart
that they don't rely on their gut
instincts
and i you know i hope that i i challenge
people to understand that information is
constantly
um being manipulated to make us believe
one narrative or the other
and sometimes it is best to trust your
best and your your gut instincts and i'm
definitely a
player and it's served me pretty well
yeah by the way
if i'm not mistaken the the little thing
between you and sam
that was started publicly and i think
you reached out to me you made a point
of it and i was able to coordinate so
you guys could talk privately instead
of doing everything publicly and we talk
about that all the time
when we see people we know go after each
other publicly and it's like
why didn't why didn't you text me you
could just call me maybe maybe i dropped
the ball on this one you know
right say this people can if in fact
check me on this i have never
publicly gone after a conservative and
has not gone after me first
and i go after them because i hate that
exactly what you're saying i i'm
responding because i'm like
every single one of you has a way to
reach me we have mutual friends it's a
small
tight-knit conservative circle so when i
see people that are tweeting
something about me about me or at me i
know they're doing it for their own ego
and for their
clicks not because they actually want to
have a resolution and to sam's credit he
tweeted something at me and then
immediately privately said let's hop on
the phone and we had a discussion and
i hung up the phone and was like you
know we're just on opposite sides of
this thing you know and that's fine too
that's totally fine
um but you know he thought that my
tweets were so responsible and they were
going to get people killed and
um and i felt otherwise and i just said
you know we're going to have to ride
this thing out because we disagree
um but i do think there needs to be a
bit more of an adult approach
on the conservative side in general like
i'm never trying to
go after you with clause on if i
disagree i'm happy to have a private
conversation with you
yeah all right well let's talk about the
other thing enough about kovid
uh racism candace it's everywhere
there's more of it
to go around than ever before it's a
miracle that they even let you use skype
right now as a black woman i mean what
do we do about this situation
i mean i think it is really time the
challenge now
is to just dear white people what the
hell have you been thinking allowing
this to go on
this far you know what i mean at this
tail in between the legs
hey look my ancestors i can at least say
we were dragged with chains and whipped
and beaten into submission white people
today i don't even know what this is
this is crazy i mean i've never seen
such people
um that are just so willing uh to to
fight for their own oppression
right to say oh i shouldn't deserve it i
should step down from my job i shouldn't
be in this room i shouldn't be able to
say anything
i should be silent for a day and it is
just such a
such an openly hostile okay society
um in terms of treating white people
poorly and but
white people have dug the grapes so it's
very bizarre to me and you know i liken
it to
um seeing a parent with a toddler like
if you're at a restaurant and the
toddler is freaking out and screaming
and there are the parents that give a
toddler what he wants and that's like
terrible
and white america when we when they see
these radicalized black people because
it's not all black people
but they get the attention right these
radicalized black people
screaming and wailing about something
they just give them what they want no
matter what it is defund the police okay
we'll just start talking about defining
the police because you've made that
ridiculous absurd demand that has never
been made ever
um and so i it's it's hard not to think
that this is actually the fault
of white guilt right this is this is
white guilt gone too far you guys are
like overdosing
on my guilt right now not me
hey not me lady i'm not guilty for
anything i haven't done
me personally but you know and so
um i always just ask please stop giving
the toddlers in the black community what
they want
and similarly i won't give your you know
freakish little antifa white
thug is what they want you know and um
and there just needs to be more people
having a bit of a spine i would say in
the white community
did you sense that this thing was coming
sort of like what we were always up
against when we would do college events
together
and it would be this odd sort of antifa
thing but we didn't know exactly what it
was and it was a little bit before blm
had like fully exposed itself to me but
all of this and as i said to you in our
other interview and as we've always done
at every event we've ever done together
we take questions from people
who disagree with us first but are you
shocked how quickly
in the last six months this thing like
molded together
and blm and antifa and the marxists
and the twitter like the whole thing
just morphed into one
really evil monster really freaking fast
all sort of under the coved thing like
it all happened at the same time
right um i wasn't shocked i mean i have
been warning about this for years i kept
saying during an election cycle you're
going to see race issues drummed up
now how violent they've gotten yes that
surprised me
um and also i would say i've been
shocked by the permission they've been
given
and the excuses and the passes they've
been given by politicians i never
foresaw
that coming i i would think a store gets
robbed looted
uh torn down burned and you know no
matter whether you're left or right
you know you would stand up and say this
is wrong the inability for politicians
to now acknowledge what's right and
what's wrong that has shocked me
uh we've hit a real low point when um
people are saying this is okay when
politicians don't have the spine and say
you know what i'm actually not okay with
finding the police
and we need to isolate this incident and
compromise this incident
and not say that every police officer is
wrong um
and so i i am shocked at how much the
left
hates america um and how much the left
hates
people that do the right thing because
that's really what it's come down to if
you do the right thing
if you earn accolades in life if you you
know climb the ladder in life they hate
you
uh and they're saying there's not a
place for you anymore if there's
something fundamentally wrong with free
markets with capitalism with
everything that american and western
ideals and western principles were built
upon so
that part shocked me but not this
narrative i i was seeing it everywhere i
went and i knew that they were organized
that they were well funded and that they
were going to come ready to fight
yeah do you how do you see
any chance of getting out of this thing
i mean as you said
you expect trump to win i think you
would think he's going to win big
i think he's probably going to win big
too and it's like no matter
if biden wins if trump wins if biden
wins big if trump wins big
it's sort of like i don't see a way we
get out of this either way
i could see some version maybe where if
trump wins by
truly a landslide like a like a reagan
re-election situation
that maybe finally the last few decent
democrats
get the kids out of the adult table like
the kids that they've let taken over
that's sort of what you were saying
before
maybe they do it themselves but that
doesn't seem
very probable to me do you see any way
we get out of this thing
well the only way we get out of it is if
people and i think we are
actually gonna are starting to get out
of it now in a weird way because people
are starting to see socialism manifest
right marxist principles manifest
they're looking around their
neighborhoods
and they're seeing you know uh stores
being looted stores being robbed
violence happening police getting shot
individual
uh cities that are gone up in crime by
something like 267 percent right
in new york city and in chicago um and
they're seeing that the suburbs are now
being threatened they're going to come
to the suburbs they're telling people in
the suburbs to leave their house
you saw i'm sure the video clip maybe
you didn't because you were away but
uh throughout dc they were going up to
white people at restaurants and
oh yeah i've seen it saying put your
fist up and say
you know black power or else you get
screamed at so these people are now
seeing
you've supported this and now you've
seen what it's become and i think that
once those people understand now not
once they see that manifest they'll
change their perspective
and they'll they'll vote differently
right and then of course once the
democrats
if the democrats lose a ton of seats it
no longer serves them
to to be funding these marxist moves no
longer serves them to stand behind the
violent criminals
it no longer serves them uh to pretend
that these criminals
were righteous and you'll see a dramatic
change in society and i think that it
will secure
as it did in england i'm hoping to see
what we saw in england
where after brexit it just every every
vote went to the tory party
um i think that we will see the same
thing in america and we'll save this
country for a lot of time to come
because people will not forget this
yeah i i sense you're kind of right you
know i hate when they say the gay
community the black community the
community thing i hate that
but you know i saw this poll just since
i've been back that at one point i guess
post the convention 24
of black for trump people we're looking
at like four percent
you know i tweeted something like a year
ago that i thought trump was going to
get 30
of the black vote and i know that might
be a little crazy but i still
i think that the the mask has been
pulled off
and i i think something crazy is going
to happen i really do
are you with me on that 100 you know
i've been saying this forever
and i was laughed at in the beginning
right when i first said blex hit and
i said that my vision had always been 20
points by 2020. i knew it was possible
uh because the left can no longer hide
from itself and i was so happy when aoc
hit the map
uh because she was just saying it you
know what i mean the old school
democrats were
hiding what they wanted and then aoc
kind of took over their party
and said no this is what we want and
they capitulated to what she was saying
and so they couldn't lie anymore right
they couldn't lie about the fact that
they were supporting these marxist
principles
and the destruction of family black
lives matter on the website destruct the
nuclear family
you know this is wrong this is backwards
so and i've just seen so many people
people you least suspect that i've
contacted me privately celebrities
that you would just go this person
posted a black square this person's a
marxist and just going
i've had an awakening and i i would like
to have a private conversation with you
offline
um and i think that that to me it just
made me feel
just so happy like all of this hasn't
been for not all the beatings that i've
taken
uh it hasn't been yeah well
so i think i asked you this six months
ago so i may be asking you the exact
same question from six months ago in the
same interview
but since some time has passed uh we
both know what the publishing world is
like and it takes a long time to get a
book out and as you said because okovid
you guys delayed it and you wanted to be
able to promote it properly and the rest
of it
um are you totally confident that
everything that you laid out in blackout
that these extreme circumstances and
this strange time that we live in
it's not going to alter any of the
things that you are writing about do you
feel like it's all
timeless enough yeah and i actually
added a chapter
uh because of you know my george floyd
video which
got something like 200 million 100
million views just on facebook
um and i wanted to double and triple
down everything that i said in that
video
um and really talk about what the black
lives matter movement is and
just remind people who tried to bully me
out of having that perspective that i
met what i meant and i said what i said
and
that that chapter that i added was
really just about culture black culture
that we've done this and it's time for
us to take responsibility that
our culture is broken that we have music
that's broken and we're you know we
we are encouraging people to believe in
this gang lifestyle and the stripper
lifestyle and this baby mama lifestyle
and it's time to stop blaming white
people and realize that we've done this
to ourselves and we're the only people
that can dick ourselves out of this hole
yeah and people seem to be waking up to
it so i'm guessing you're not a huge fan
of
whap i just heard about whap i'm a
little behind
wow yes i don't think you and i will be
coordinating a dance to that anytime
soon
unless you want to and you've seen
you've seen me dance
it won't be pretty actually literally
the last time i danced was at your
wedding and it's probably the last time
i'll dance for the next
year anyway um so it seems like i mean i
can tell
i said to you right before we started
the recording you sort of have that
pregnant glow to you but but you seem
like particularly happy to me which
you know these days everyone when i was
off the grid and people would recognize
me or come up to me or if someone came
to my house
everyone would say oh dave it's so much
worse it's so much worse
and it struck me how depressed people
are
by the news you know i i try to i take
this stuff seriously and i know it's
serious but i also do try to
separate myself from it that's why i do
the august thing
um but but you get a ton of hate as i
said you get a ton of love but like you
really do seem happy in the midst of all
of this which i think is
probably weird for some people to see
i'm so happy it's crazy i wake up every
day and i'm like i'm the happiest person
and it
can seem totally bizarre but my
perspective
is just that all i've ever wanted was
for in this crazy game of political
poker for the left to just lay down all
of their cards and show us their hand
and they're doing that um and so it's
there's this quickening happening right
now where people are starting to finally
understand
my perspective perspective of so many
other people that have been fighting
um alongside me i mean on top of that i
have
a husband um you know that i love i've
been you know
recently got married i'm having a baby
i'm having the easiest pregnancy ever
um i work out all the time and i'm just
happy vibes all the time
and i right now also am sensing
bizarrely that
even amidst all of the different
conservative connections that
we're all starting to bond a bit better
um and we're starting to understand that
we all have different strategies
um but us fighting and pulling each
other wasn't really working and i just
i sense more unity in the conservative
movement and more focus
which i'm thrilled about um and so i
just have nothing to be upset about
i literally am the happiest person i'm
just like guys
it's all going to be fine we're fighting
we're on the good guys side the good the
good guys always win so
the good guys always win well listen
candice we could do a lot more but i
actually think that's the perfect moment
to just give people the other hour that
we did together and and it stands on its
own
um but i just wanted to chat with you
anyway so that's why we did this mostly
guys never forget that when i was
coughing blood my friend wanted me
to get tested for coca-19
excuse me dave rubin made you eggs made
you eggs
where when you didn't know where you
were gonna sleep that night
that really i mean people people can't
understand it's not just that you were
telling me you were coughing up blood
but you're coughing
you're sneezing we're watching the nba
season got cancelled i think right
then i saw the video and then your
assistant was with us
too and she's coughing and she's
sneezing and they're telling us we're
all gonna die
and i let you stay till about nine
o'clock at night
you did it that's a true friend guys
there you go
uh candace it was great seeing as always
we're gonna play the full interview now
and i hope to see you in real life one
of these days i think we're gonna make
it happen
sounds good guys enjoy the interview how
long has it been it's been about
since the original interview and
did i launch that in 2017 you did it
like i'm you were one of my first
interviews
you and paul joseph watson were my first
two um so i think that was 2017.
yeah so let's say it's about three years
uh you were on the show one other time
for some other thing we'll just let that
one be for now not not important to get
into that one uh some people probably
know what i'm talking about but it
doesn't matter
um but yeah so it's been about three
years at the time we were doing youtube
week here
and i just tweeted out i need to find
some youtubers that are interesting i
want to do five shows with five
different youtubers in five days blah
blah blah
a couple people said you gotta check out
red pill black
we watched your your first video which
was sort of about announcing
to your family that you're a
conservative that kind of caught you on
fire we brought you in here
it feels like another lifetime ago
doesn't it because it was
it definitely was a another lifetime ago
it's it's totally bizarre
um to consider that was just three years
ago and how much has gone on and how
much has changed and
how much i've changed how much i've
grown things that i've learned and
i feel like when i was sitting across
from you those years ago i was so naive
to what i was about to be thrown into
the middle of
for better or for worse i was naive and
now i'm much more seasoned much more
experienced and much more sure of myself
how have you managed to stay sane
through the machine so cause yeah you
really were just
i mean kid in a certain way like i feel
like we were kids
and it's only three years ago and it's
not like we're 18 but we were sort of
kids in this thing
you started just saying what you thought
um one of the moments
we've we've discussed this many times
privately where i was like oh candace is
the real deal
is there was a question that i asked you
about the surveillance state
in that first interview and you
basically said i don't have an opinion i
need to know more
and i was like well nobody does that
that's where you're supposed to make up
some [ __ ] but
but you you actually said that and i
thought this is someone who will learn
going forward
i think i think that's definitely what
separated me from other people is i've
just remained
really authentic i'm not trying to be an
expert on everything i've been honest
about the fact that i'm learning
um and i say now that i've pretty much
grown up politically in front of
everybody's faces they've seen my
awkward
braces to use an analogy in my brace
phase and
the pimple phase of me being in politics
and there were things that i
genuinely did not know i had never heard
of because i spent my entire life not
being politically inclined
um and then suddenly i am on your show
because i just had a feeling
more than a fact right i had a feeling
that black americans were being duped
and that none of it really added up none
of it made any sense
and i wanted to convert those feelings
into facts and start really doing the
work and studying
and some people wanted to push me as
now you're the leader you must know
everything um when i wasn't ready to do
that
um and other people were trying to make
me
stand by the go go through these purity
tests if you will the puritan
conservatives
and then i have a left trying to destroy
me the puritan conservatives trying to
prove that i wasn't
uh what i was i guess held up to be
um and it was it was crappy it was
really crappy because i'm sitting here
going guys i'm literally just telling
you
i've been authentic i haven't said that
people should be following me over you
know into
into another area or anything like that
um but i survived it because i'm
authentic and and i wasn't scared i was
never scared to be myself
why not why not not scared to be
yourself but why weren't you scared by
the attacks like when twitter puts their
lead story
is basically you know on the search bar
was like you know something like candace
owens is all right which eventually they
took down after you
respond because you always punch back
but what do you think it is about you
specifically
that you know because a lot of people
fear this thing they know who they are
they want to fight but they just
fear the monster you know i think it's
for me what's really aided me is
perspective
um so i've i've had people they're all
stressed out about
twitter and facebook and all these
things and to me i think first and
foremost being someone that came from
nothing
you know a person that was not raised in
a family that had any financial means
uh who grew up poor my perspective is a
bit different and i think to myself if
the biggest complaint i have today
um is that i'm trending on twitter about
something that i didn't say or was
taking out of context and i'm remarkably
blessed
um a couple of generations ago my
grandfather was picking cotton and
laying out tobacco dry on a share
cropping farm
i couldn't look him in the face and say
i've had a really stressful day because
i'm trending on twitter that's not what
i said so it's it's just perspective
yeah you have
to and i also have a tremendously good
sense of humor yeah
you do you do well what is the
part of you that is actually political
because you you don't really strike me
like when we hang out separately like we
always talk politics
but we talk about a lot of other stuff
and we and it's usually cultural what
we're really talking about but
but you're thought of as like this
political beast like okay this is going
to be president or again it's going to
be senators
you know something like that i mean i
remind people of what andrew brabart
said about
politics is downstream from culture it's
such an important thing he's so accurate
with that
the reason why things weren't changing
and conservative ideas weren't winning
in society is because conservatives
by and large suck up their nose to
culture and i say that as somebody
who had to go through the conservative
ring of fire too
people know obviously if the left
routinely attacks me and that they've
attacked me since i started making
youtube videos
but they forget that conservatives
attacked me too you know one of the
first hit pieces that was written about
me was written by the national review
and i'll never forget the sentence this
is the sort of conservatism that we need
to reject
is what they wrote this is the sort of
because i was making funny videos
because i was making people understand
big concepts because i wasn't writing
a 95 thesis you know 95 theses and
stapling it to a wall and saying here
you go guys
right you weren't in a think tank funded
by a gajillion dollars yeah
i was just on youtube taking some
complex topics and being conversational
um and that same kind of uh vein of
conservatism are the people that
thoroughly rejected donald trump donald
trump is cultural
he takes complex topics and he he
dilutes them down to something that
feels tangible
um that somebody who who's a a
normal individual that's a hard worker
can understand hashtag lock her up right
he's saying a lot in there
right there's corruption it's been going
on for a long time something needs to
change
it's a swamp right um people hate how
colloquial that is but people respond
um to a more colloquial manner and
discuss and how i speak i don't speak to
my
cousins like i'm giving a thesis paper i
talked to them conversationally and that
was my style
but candace has someone that's had
dinner with that trump guy
and has been to the oval office and done
other things with that trump guy i
thought i thought he hates black people
i saw on cnn he's a racist and a
homophobe
it's crazy and and i think i'm i'm
fortunate fortunate
um that the the media continually
overplays their hand
it's fortunate because it's the reason
that i exist and anybody who has a
modicum of intelligence
knows that this man has been in the
media for decades he was never accused
of being racist sexist bigoted homophobe
none of those things then suddenly he
runs for
president united states and he's all of
those things um so for me it just gave
me pause and i just said this can't be
right
um i i by no means in that moment when
he came on the escalator thought he
should be president of the united states
um but i also wasn't dense enough to
believe that as he came down that
escalator he suddenly became the
literally hitler white supremacist that
cnn msnbc tried to turn him into
so i appreciate the media um and them
them constantly smearing and libeling
people because i think that it's
actually it's working in our favor
and it's working on the side of truth
because more people are questioning
their relationship with the media
so how does someone like you balance the
identity politics that you hate that we
constantly mock versus as you always say
to me
you just want black people to think for
themselves or or have black people
realize they don't have to be democrats
so there it is twanged with
identity politics right brexit is
twanged with it
and i always say when people ask me this
that it's i have to use their rules
against them sort of something like that
but how do you balance that
well i think it's it's understanding the
difference between identity and identity
politics
so i am happy to be black i think black
can be an identity i think jewish can be
an identity
i think uh part of your identity can be
if i was pregnant and i wanted uh to
take a
class and sit around with a bunch of
pregnant moms and talk about the
struggles that we're going through
that's not identity politics
that's all of us coming together because
we share a certain identity
and and we're talking about certain
things that are relevant to us black
americans convening to talk about things
that are relevant for them
is identity politics if i was using
blexit um
and at our blexit events we were saying
you need to vote for donald j
trump you need to stop being a democrat
and start being a republican
um that would be identity politics um
because of the color of your skin
it's quite the opposite um we're talking
about why the color of our skin and the
dialogue and the race dialogue is
meaningless
um we're talking about taking
responsibility for things that are going
on
um in in amongst our communities
um that we have been the perpetuators of
you know we talk about
police brutality in a real context we
talk about that weight against black on
black crime
um i think the only way that black
community gets fixed is that the black
community
sort of realizes that we do have an
identity um that we've made a lot of
errors that we continue to make a lot of
mistakes and we say you know what it's
time for us to stop blaming the white
man
it's time for us to stop looking
externally and start looking internally
on how we can make a difference
so when you see trump do the state of
the union and he talks about the lowest
black unemployment all the time and
immediately the headlines say no no no
that was because of obama which even if
perhaps some of that is true perhaps
uh well the guy didn't wreck it so that
that seems pretty good
but more importantly that when you see
the congressional black caucus
and they sit there with their arms
folded over the lowest all-time black
unemployment
now that something doesn't add up there
right it doesn't add up because when
obama gave his state of the union and he
announced more food stamps and more
welfare they stood up and they applauded
i got a standing ovation
um so that's the kind of stuff that you
can just use
um to ask black americans why is that
why did rashida talib walk
out um when trump announced that less
people were
filing for welfare and food stamps she
said she walked out and she said
they were having something taken from
them and she just couldn't bear anymore
and she walked out
well she also said impeach the
[ __ ] the day that she got
uh elected i mean literally so it's like
was this a fair judge of what's going on
here
right and what you realize is that um
what they want for black americans is to
be a permanent underclass they
they need black americans to be
dependent upon the government um and
that's just the truth and we are
dependent upon the government by and
large we are dependent upon the
government
um we've allowed the government uh to
come in and and father our families
um you know with the great society act
in the 1960s systematically removing
black men from the home
um and and making black women bitter and
that's an interesting thing
and one that i haven't talked about
enough but um people always ask me you
know what are some of the issues facing
the black community
um we're not a community we don't know
how to communicate we don't know how to
do conflict resolution
especially black women and you know this
this whole stereotype of an angry black
woman
um where does that really come from i've
been having those sort of those sorts of
early conversations well it comes from
the fact
that black women have had to do things
by themselves because they've allowed
uh the government to tell them that they
should be doing things by themselves and
after
after decades of allowing this this
whole baby daddy
uh phenomenon to break out into our
communities right and now we're saying
to men they don't need to be responsible
because the government will step in and
give us more money if they're not inside
of the homes
you have this this new epidemic where
you have you know black women that are
upset they can't really pinpoint why it
is that they're upset
um and nothing's really changing and
nothing's really been productive so
there's so much that's fraction in my
community that has nothing to do with
white man
the jewish man the hispanic man nothing
we have accepted
government um as our source and our
solution for everything and
simultaneously broken apart our families
so so one of the things that i think
you've explained really well which is
right off that
is that generally again the black
community which is a bit of an amorphous
term generally actually there the values
usually do lean more conservative and
it's only through sort of media tricks
that they don't realize that something
like that can you talk about that a
little bit yeah
absolutely i mean we're naturally
conservative i mean even when
all of the candidates were running and
and people were trying to take
pete buddha judge seriously and i
immediately said this is all a farce
pretending that pete buddha judge
is is going to be the presidential
candidate for the democrats is a joke
because he's gay right and he's a gay
married man and
he's running as a democrat and the
democrats um need the black vote the
black community
will not vote for a gay married man to
be the candidate that's just a fact
whether people like that makes them
uncomfortable doesn't mean anything so
is that a religious
thing is that it is christianity
absolutely
and and and black people are deeply
faithful and every poll showed that
right and you saw the leftists ignoring
that piece of evidence oh well
we're not going to look at the fact that
black people are polling very low and
then they're not okay with the fact that
he's married to a black man because they
don't want to accept reality
um so that first and foremost right so
on the lgbt stuff the black community is
fiercely fiercely fiercely conservative
especially when it comes to the trans
stuff there was a remarkable video
um of a black pastor and it doesn't you
can't see what he's looking at but
there's a congregation
and he looks straight down at the man he
says you need to leave my you need to
leave this church
when you come and i don't care what you
do outside of this church
but when you come here on sundays you
come dressed as a man
and he was speaking to obviously a trans
individual man that was wearing a dress
or dressed as a woman
and he kicked him out of the church and
the entire black congregation started
applauding
right that that is that is the black
community on lgbt issues right
um if you asked what would you like to
would you like to see something change
there i mean as someone that i know you
have
gay friends we're friends and by the way
i completely separate the tea thing
the trans thing from the gay i
i think that what i'm talking about
right now is just the reality in terms
of like
not black people leaning more
conservatively naturally um 100
i i hope that the black community is at
the forefront of standing up to the
trans stuff i never want to see that
i never want to see that change and i
think that is incumbent upon the gay
community
um to to just to expel it you you take
the tea off or or or we're not playing
the game right
if this if you're saying that now this
is a package deal and that somehow
you being a married gay man means that
in order for me to accept
that i have to also take um drag queens
and and men that are dressed as women
and them being allowed to go into
women's restrooms no i'm not playing the
game well the other part that i hate
about it is that i have no more insight
into what it is like to be a trans
person than you do
right you know what i mean i am in the
body i am supposed to be in
yeah nothing to do with each other
you're talking about a sexual preference
uh versus a mental disorder a mental
disorder is the right way to call if you
are telling me that your mind
and your physical are out of order right
that that is a mental disorder or
whether you want to call a physical
disorder a mental disorder it is a
disorder
right and and to conflate that with a
sexual preference which doesn't impact
me
right but does you being married to a
gay man impact me
you've been here for many nights does it
impact me does me being married to
to a straight man impact you okay but if
suddenly like i said a part of you
accepting the fact that me and my
husband are married
means that you have to also accept the
fact that you know your child
is now going to be exposed to men
dressed as women and be read to by a
drag queen and over sexualize and all of
this stuff that comes with with the
trans movement which i view
as evil i really do it's something that
i'm very opposed to
um that that's what i see is where it
gets problematic and there needs to be
there needs to be more gay people
speaking out against it and saying that
we're not just going to let you put this
on our wagon
right and and so i mean that's something
i'm passionately against and i've been
against it since i've been on your show
yeah yeah well douglas murray who i know
you've talked to i mean he's and who
happens to be gay i mean i think he's
really led the charge the book's over
here somewhere
right where he separates these two
things they just have nothing to do with
each other
just to clean all of that up for the for
the people that will clip this and go oh
candace hates trans people yeah yeah how
would you like if
if a trans person that worked at a place
that you work at or
a trans person that you met on the
street or had coffee with or something
how would you like them to be treated
under the law and the rest
they should be always be protected this
this concept of like because i don't
want to now adapt
my life uh to the way that you prefer to
uh
lead yours now means i somehow think
that you should be harmed or hurt no
this is america you should be you should
be afforded the exact same protections
i'm preferred
under the law right but if i woke up one
day and said that i was superman
and i said now all of a sudden we have
to legislate the fact that i think i'm
superman
that's crazy i mean we have to accept
that there are various
other disorders too in this world the
mental disorders in this world people
that suffer from schizophrenia
bipolar all of these things the
difference is is that we encourage them
to get help and we don't demand
that the whole world pretend and shift
um to accommodate their their various
illnesses right if somebody
schizophrenic
or somebody is suffering from split
personality disorder we don't say okay
well you get two votes uh because you're
you think you're two people right that's
the trans argument patience patience
patience you're right given just a
couple of years democrats would be on
that too
uh but that's the trend that that's the
trans argument which is that because
this is what i'm going through gender
dysphoria which is very real by the way
um everyone now must adapt we must
pretend that there's 36 genders when
there's just not
um and and then to call people that
acknowledge and can see reality for what
it is
um bigoted or or or saying they have a
phobia
is just wrong and and it's it's not and
it's not an area where i'm willing to
give up um
uh any any uh yards on the football
field yeah so
so when you see trump addressing you
know
the employment issues with the black
community and you understand that
from your perspective that the
conservative that the black community is
more
i hate i just hate saying the community
word it's just
black people blacks yeah but even that
like i because they're because of course
there's
just all these different types of black
people of course but but by
by and large or whatever you want to
call it um so
unemployment down he's also doing some
stuff on criminal justice reform i mean
we were
we were at in dc we did an event and we
went to the trump hotel for a drink and
uh helped me with the woman's name now
we met the woman that he got out of jail
alice johnson yeah um i mean he's done
some some pretty good stuff there too
he's done some really good stuff and and
i will say this it's great that we're
addressing
some of these um you know older policies
that were put in place uh first and
foremost like the things that were put
in place by the clintons themselves
um that definitely did disadvantage
black men and i've realized that
um i do see a disconnect and this is
where i go separate from a lot of
conservatives on this issue because i
have found that some conservatives
are hardcore on criminal justice and
they say use something bad you locked up
throw away the key and you're done with
it
and and that to me shows that they have
not had much of an experience with
people that end up in the system
i do agree that about above a certain
age you can enough crimes um you
basically
it becomes very hard for you to come
back from that but when people are young
and they're committing their first
offense and it's the first time they're
going into prison so much change can
happen
other their circumstances are usually
being led by you know i have uncles that
have spent their lives and out of prison
um when you're completely impoverished
and your back back is against the wall
when you don't have your father at home
um sort of the natural direction that
you trend to is towards the streets
because you will pursue that paternity
elsewhere right so if you are not
getting that guidance from mom and dad
because they're not at home you're not
having dinner around the table at night
you're still gonna want somebody to be
the mom and dad so that's lead you to
the streets that could lead you to
culture that leads you to hip-hop
suddenly
jay-z and and and kanye or mom and dad
whenever they're telling you if
somebody's saying grab a gap go outside
you think that that's the direction that
you should be into
um so there's so much that happens when
you talk about the the father the
fatherless problem that we have in the
black community
and if you can get them in prison and
you can make just just
small differences in terms of helping
them transition when they get out
you know i've been in prison for two
years you're gonna give me fifty dollars
in a bus ticket
and you expect me not to go back to
crime um
those are the things that are that are
really important and i spent some time
two years ago
uh visiting some prisons and speaking to
the inmates um and it really woke me up
to that
now on the other side of that and where
conservatives are getting it right
um is that this is not you can't make
the argument that because there's a lot
of black people in the system
um that the system is rotten uh black
people we we commit more crimes uh
that is just uh the truth we are
disproportionately represented in the
prison system because we are
disproportionately committing crime
goes back to that thesis of we got to be
more responsible
yeah yeah there's a lot there okay so
if why is this stuff so hard for people
to understand do you think like is that
purely just because of the cultural
aspect
that you just constantly get the reverse
message
yeah it's not hard for people to
understand it's people don't want to
understand it
um i i say now that nobody ever won
um an election cycle on the slogan of be
more responsible
right nobody wants to hear that nobody
wants to hear be more responsible
um and and that's the truth a lot of
these things in these issues that we
have in society are because people are
not being more responsible because
people are making bad decisions
and unfortunately um going back to
culture yes we have a culture that tells
it it's okay
to not be responsible so there it's okay
to offset all of your issues it's okay
to blame you know external institutions
uh for the problems that you're dealing
with internally
um so it becomes easy and like i said
looking yourself in the mirror and
saying i
am a i am bad in this way or i need to
correct this
it's hard um and most people just don't
have the humility to do it do you find
it funny the way they always end up
turning it on themselves too so once you
use racism or sexism or homophobia as
the tool it always ends up coming back
on you so like cory booker gets out of
the race
next thing you know cory booker's saying
that you know it's because of racism
uh any of the any elizabeth warren gets
out everyone says it's because of sexism
but it's like guys
uh it was the democratic primary it was
your people
it wasn't those evil republicans it
wasn't those evil conservatives
it was your people so you're saying your
people are racist and and actually that
is what they're saying and
perhaps there's some truth there right
and what they say basically if i don't
get what i want there's there's
something bigger happening
there's something bigger going on how
sweet is that it's the best thing ever
and actually
i was just responding to a tweet when i
came in here but um
though the woman who had that big uh
mathematical hysterical did you see that
uh gay is her last name is it is it
marcy gay
yeah i think it's marcy gay from the new
york times 500 million
divided by 300 million equals one
million or something
that basically bloomberg with the 500
million that bloomberg spent on the
on the campaign he could have given
every american
a million dollars a million dollars yeah
and brian williams agreed with him and
apparently the researchers and all it's
like we're in here i got a couple crew
members in there but we're just doing
our thing right
it's like nobody's got no ifb here with
someone telling me numbers they have a
whole series of people in there right
and yes 500 million could actually give
a million people to every american 350
million
150 million americans so her math on
that is 500 million divided by 350
million americans
um but putting aside the math mistake i
don't think that's where you're going
with it yeah well
because then she tweeted i don't know if
you saw that yeah i saw it i saw it
she's written an article saying that the
racist
mob is not going to stop her because of
her her she had to endure
you know racism because of her
mathematical error and
and how pathetic is that i mean really
think about that this is what really
frustrates me
this this whole concept of black people
being strong are we acting strong right
now
no we're acting pathetic right you can't
accept that people are mocking you
because you did something that was
ridiculous and embarrassing you know
what would be strong
you owning it and making fun of yourself
what would be funny would be you going
on saturday night live and doing a whole
skit
like trying to calculate things and
being not going to be making you
likeable
people like that's the girl you know
just just laugh at yourself have a sense
of humor we all make mistakes you know
we all
sometimes get it completely wrong or say
something ridiculous but for you to say
even something that's small right you
make a mathematical error and you're
still able to transform that
into a moment of racism because black
people cannot be wrong on anything
even when they're literally factually
mathematically incorrect
it's because people are racist and it's
such a trap door too because brian
williams came off looking as
as ignorant and confused as she did but
brian williams didn't make an excuse for
it that it had you know what i mean
and also i quickly glanced at the
twitter feed when she posted the
the new york times article and it was
like people weren't calling her
race there was nobody saying anything
racist nobody was saying oh that black
woman
is stupid because she's black like there
was nothing like that it was like you
it was basically like you're both idiots
like it was a lot of that not to say
that no racist
person got in there and said something
lord knows that i'm sure they did
but like the knee-jerk response to go oh
my get out of jail free card
is right it's this right and what it
what it really speaks to is the fact
that i really believe that in this
moment in time
black people are looking pathetic that
the people that we have leading
um culturally look pathetic um this
whole you know jesse smullet is
pretending he
you know he's uh launching racist
attacks on himself
right hiring big black men oh if you're
gonna pay to do it
pay some white guys at least go with it
so when we see the images
it looks like you maybe thought it was
white people that were doing this to you
um but it it's it's um it's happening
more and more
and another example of that is there was
the young black girl and i can't think
of her name at the moment
who said that white boys attacked her in
school it was karen pence's school but
she teaches that yeah
and they cut off her dreadlocks and they
called her racial slurs the entire thing
was made up right
what bothers me about that situation of
that young black girl doing that is that
it's not her fault
right she is now being raised in an
environment where black people are
aspiring to victimhood
right she's seeing her idols she's
seeing the colin kaepernicks the jesse
smallidge the whoever this is that wrote
the new york times
aspire to victim like it's like it's
some like you get an award at the end
like you get a trophy and it's this is
an amazing thing you get to be a victim
and you get to be a star now because
everyone's going to come behind you and
they're going to feel bad for you you're
going to get awards you're going to get
acolytes
so this poor young girl i actually
genuinely my heart hurt for her
because she was so young and for her to
do that there was no other reason that
she that she's a product of an
environment
of black victimhood and and there's not
enough black americans
that are able to take a joke right just
basic things i say to you you know what
i'm not living in this
simulation of white versus black and
that's what i think that
is going to be the next natural
generation of black kids just wanting to
be a victim
all the time so when you've gone to
blexit events and do all of the things
you're doing do you sense that that
thing is just
basically ready to crack like when i've
seen the videos of the events that you
do it's like the joy that is in that
room
is incredible it's absolutely incredible
it's way more joyous
than if you were to go to some event
where you'd be up there going
you know the the republicans did this to
you and we're going to give you more of
this like there's no joy related to any
of that and and people want to be joyous
yeah
and one of the things one of the things
you always told me from the beginning is
how pissed you were that the way that
that black people stopped being funny
because black people
are naturally funny naturally funny
black people jews
naturally funny there's something about
going through struggle and that gives
you
a sense of humor like yeah the outsider
perspective and a sense of humor gets
you through tough times it really does
um and that was kind of we cornered the
market on that
on a sense of humor and i always talk
about the old stand-up routines
um and bigger and blacker is the one
that comes to mind it's the one i
watched most recently just
a great it is a perfect perfect sandwich
perfect about it
because he's so racist to everyone he
goes in there the first thing he says is
yeah white people are in the back
tonight right and then everyone starts
laughing and by the time he's done
he's insulted black people the baby mama
drama he's insulted white people jewish
people school shootings
he even went there at that time this was
in like 1990 uh but he starts being like
oh that's a white person crime you know
what i mean they talk about differences
between white crimes and black crimes
yeah he's got that great line about
um he's like people think black people
don't like jews but like we hate
all of you yeah right and everyone's
laughing
and it's incredible because by the end
of it you suddenly realize
that you all kind of suck right and
you're in your various ways
and you feel closer and you feel better
for it that is what humor is always it's
supposed to be it was always supposed to
be medicinal
it was supposed to be a way of saying
that like your problems aren't as big as
the problems the person next to you
and we all suck and this is kind of the
condition of life and we're doing this
together
you can't do that anymore right if he
did that skit today go back and i mean
go back and watch it
he would be cancelled before i mean it
would be insane
it would be he would be canceled before
he got out the first joke and they'd
like this is
this is not funny i can't white people
in the back
tonight this is completely inappropriate
i mean like
that would be the critics today yeah oh
god
it's all it's so nuts or look at look at
what's his name that guy
he was going to host the oscars kevin uh
you know what
a tweet kevin what's his name kevin hart
kevin hart yeah yeah a tweet uh
from years ago one more than 10 years
ago
whatever right and and i'll tell you
what's wrong with that the bigger issue
with that the first thing is he
shouldn't have backed down and i thought
that that was an example of black people
being pathetic he should have stood his
ground and that that's what i love about
um
give me the black community and that uh
dave dave
chappelle i love dave his ground um he
to me is is he saving black humor right
now and people
won't realize until his legacy settles
of what he's doing um but aside from
that remove kevin hart
um and think about this next generation
of kids um we were afforded
i was facebook started when i was in
high school right so i got to be a kid
there was no social media my dad had a
beeper when i was growing up
and i got to became what i mean by god
to be a kid i got to be a crappy human
being
because part of growing up is
experimenting with being a crappy human
being
it's looking you in the face and saying
you know what you're fat right
i either liked the way that sounded or
like the way personal reaction okay you
know i was a mean person i didn't like
that yeah
um trying when i had aim like you know
just something mean to say
yeah i can say whatever i want um and we
didn't have a society who could capture
our old god could you imagine if the old
aim chats came back
they'd be like candace is cancelled in
third grade for saying something
my handle was brat's brat for life like
you know i mean like
ridiculous stuff but the purpose of
growing up is to experiment
with who you want to be and kids are
notoriously mean
they're picking on each other they're
getting bullied and now you're saying to
kids that what you do
um even if it's 20 years ago you can get
wiped out you could you could say
something in a whatsapp and if it gets
pulled out
your chances of employment your chances
of going anywhere you're done you're
canceled from society
if people don't realize now how that's
going to contribute to depression and
suicide
um to me it's just something that nobody
has thought about that well
it's anti-human actually because it is
your job as a human
to to say what you think to be who you
want to be
and they're trying to model for young
people no
don't do it well that's why i always say
i mean you're that's why you are
dangerous you tell people the complete
reverse
right people have said to me by the way
political advice you know candace every
uh six months you should just go back
and cancel your tweets so they're not
lingering there i go why
why would i be if someone brought up a
tweet from nine years ago i'm gonna be
like yeah i changed my mind
right i also don't think barbies are the
coolest thing anymore i changed my mind
since i was three years old
right evolution is normal even with that
car we will look right that cool car
she's driving in malibu
yeah um but but people what the left has
done is they've made it seem like
there's something fundamentally wrong
about evolution like it's not supposed
to happen
we all evolve we all evolve you are not
the same person that you were 10 years
ago you're not going to be the same
person in this room that you're going to
be 10 years from now
that is a part that's a part of the
human condition and when you start to
acquise that mentality and you say i'm
going to just delete you know i said
something in a tweet that i should have
maybe not said i'll just delete it so i
don't have to pay for it
20 years from now you're requesting to
something that that people
will not be able to survive in the
future so i keep it up because if
somebody asked me why i said that
i would say it doesn't matter if i said
it the question is do i still believe it
right that's the better question to ask
me have i evolved since that opinion not
that there's some harm
in having a thought or having the wrong
idea or being wrong in the first place
and by the way it's not just your
thoughts that they want you to worry
about it's other people that you're
associated with
thought so sometimes scary candace owens
tweet something and i'll get a text
message
from somebody like a public person and
they'll say dave
candice said that you know are you gonna
say something
as if as if you're my pet i keep you in
a little bag and it's like
oh yes i control candace and i have any
right to tell her what to do with the
rest of it but even that idea that it's
not just what you say
it's that now we want to keep you really
worried about who you might be friends
with and who you might follow on twitter
and i don't play that game and by the
way i think that's also something that
separates me from most conservatives you
know
people that go mainstream and and i i
for what it's worth i've gone mainstream
i obviously do the big network networks
i've been on fox news
um they suddenly start being very
careful about who they associate with
like you have to pretend you don't speak
to certain people or you don't know
certain people
or else you know you might catch it
whatever it is right and
a case in point a paul joseph watson was
the first person to have me on the show
you were the second
yeah um and paul joseph watson and my
husband are friends um so i'm supposed
to pretend because paul joseph watson
used to be the editor at large at
infowars
that i don't speak to paul joseph lawson
he and i aren't friends i'm not gonna do
that
i can't be fake right so if if you think
that some condition of me saying well
candace you can only stay mainstream is
if you pretend that you don't speak to
anybody that's ever been associated with
infowars i'm not that that's crappy and
conservatives need to stop
playing that game well also because so
many of these people and we see this all
the time and i won't out people right
now but that are privately going to
parties together and going to dinners
together but then won't associate
publicly
i i i and that's why you're seeing this
uprising by the way of of conservatives
who are saying these are the neocons and
this is
what they're really getting at and i
don't agree with any a lot of their
ideas is that people are
are are scared right at the same time
that you're saying you're fighting the
left you're playing by their games
okay so if you're going to say that you
you hate and you hate infowars i don't
watch infowars i've never watched
infowars but
you know because they're they're they're
fraudulent and they're fake news and all
this stuff but you'll go on cnn
i don't know how that works right if you
go on a network that routinely refers to
people as white supremacists nazis and
all of this stuff
um to me i have my ideas these are my
ideas about black america
whether i'm speaking to you whether i'm
speaking to paul joseph watson whether
i'm speaking to don lemon
and whether i'm speaking to somebody on
fox news i'm the same candice right so
the environment that i'm in doesn't
really matter for me
because i'm not sanctioning their ideas
if i go on cnn i am not agreeing with
everything don lemon has ever said
if i am going on the rhythm report i am
not saying that i agree with everything
that you have ever said
and conservatives should stand by that
that should be across
the board like it is okay to speak to
people that you disagree with you're not
going to
catch something if you talk to people
that you do not that you
do not agree with every single thing
that they say yeah and that there's a
there's a
cowardice about that well also you see
this crazy version where putting
whatever you might think about infors
and i also i i was on
once i did alex jones once but i've
literally never watched it you know i
see the
these memes well you don't see them
anymore because people are afraid to get
banned but you see
memes of the guy screaming and gay frogs
or the rest of it whatever it doesn't
even matter
but trump gave his big coronavirus
speech last night and i was watching
cnn because i do try occasionally to
flip through just to get a
feel of what's going on and cnn comes
back and it's uh
chris cuomo and uh who's
jim acosta and they immediately go into
tr within within 30 seconds of trump's
speech he gives
probably the most important speech the
president's given in you know at least a
decade or something right
and they immediately go to his
xenophobic language
and it's like guys that's not news
right it's not news it's not news it's
not news i totally agree and
and i think that you guys cnn you were
calling it the wuhan virus two weeks ago
right and now because he says it's from
china it's racist
yeah i mean it's true and and this is
the environment that we're in
unfortunately and i think that
um it's incumbent for conservatives not
to play by the left's rules and what i
mean by that is even
you know i i don't watch infowars but i
think that pretending
that alex jones is this big villainous
character is wrong
it's wrong i i think that we know people
watching i assume
from what i've seen the clips it's like
the wwe
of politics it's like making voices
sounds like entertainment you know what
i mean and all these
to pretend that every person that
watches him is like some like young
white supremacist in training is just
irresponsible and sloppy
um and i i just try to be um authentic
in terms of the way that i view all
people and i'm not going to suddenly
because i'm
accepted into the mainstream uh it you
know to pretend that well i'm not that
kind of concerned i'm not
that kind of uh whoever it is and i
think there's been a lot of that in the
conservative movement and we need to
stop that sort of like puritan
um uh i guess a puritan perspective that
i see a lot of people are holding right
now so i want to get into some of the
things that we
disagree on and we actually i just did
your show yesterday and we we unearthed
a lot of it and
hopefully we can take it a little
further right now but what do you make
of the the never trump conservatives who
are now
suddenly they were like all suddenly
socialists
yeah like it was like one thing to be
never trump that could be your position
so
so be it you don't like his attitude you
don't like the way he tweets the rest of
it
fully you may not like his policies from
a right perspective
but they're suddenly all like they kind
of like bernie now or they're like all
on team biden it's like one thing to be
against one guy
but how can you be a conservative and be
for biden or something like that right
so here's what i'll say um so and
correct me if i'm wrong glenn beck used
to be
a never trumper glenn back but he was on
the right yeah yeah
so glenn beck was in every trouble
because i spoke to glenn beck i did a
show a few weeks ago
and what we talked about we were talking
about evolution and saying that like you
know there were tons of people that were
never trump you know
good reasons or bad reasons like you
know the people weren't sure about him
myself included when he first came down
the escalator um the people that have
kept that up at this point
um or have have said are just suffering
from extreme arrogance
right and and they kept it up so much
that they're now saying oh i'd rather be
on the side of socialism
you're basically saying that you want so
badly to be right
um about this person that you have been
so against right you've taken such a
hard
hard drawn such a hard line in the sand
about hating him
um that you're actually willing to
accept things that you know will
fundamentally reverse the country that
you live in
um that will fundamentally break down
the fabric of america just so you can be
right
i can think of no greater example of
narcissism yeah
it's just like this perpetually endless
well also because the outrage sort of
goes to where you were saying
before it's like that you they need this
endless outrage to kind of keep this
machine like that that's how they define
themselves right so you need it and it's
always a lot easier to be the complainer
than the doer
right like that's uh that's it right
there but all right let's get into some
of the stuff we talked about yesterday
because
you were asking me you're going dave and
i've heard it before
dave what do you mean you're still a
liberal you're still a classical liberal
come on you're a conservative and we
unearthed some of that one of the things
i said to you is what i would love to
see a space
for people on the right and
conservatives or republicans whatever
you want to call it
to carve out some room for sensible
pro-choice people
and i don't really see it right now and
my position would not be to try to
convince
people on the right to be more
pro-choice at all
but i happen to agree with people on the
right about most of the other things so
i'd like to see a bit of a wider
tent there well i hope that i have
carved out that space you know because i
felt the same way when i became a
conservative that it was like you need
to
say all this instantly and agree with
all this instantly um or you're not
really a conservative sort of a thing
um and i think that there needs to be
exactly what you said a wider tent and
we can't become what we hate the left
puts everybody up to these purity tests
and says if you don't agree with if you
agree with me 99 of the time you
disagree with me one percent you're not
allowed to be
um on the boat um and i need not just on
the boat now we have to drown
now we have to drive
and i think that we have to be conscious
as conservatives not to do the exact
same thing and
i know that in terms of the pro-choice
thing i have been a person that i think
has been
more accepting than anybody in the
conservative movement um because uh you
remember
sitting on your show and you and you
first asked me and i said i'm gonna
kind of not say what i think about this
just yet because i wasn't ready and i
didn't have my opinions
um formulated on the basis of fact yet
um my opinion is that i'm pro-life
um and but i i know that there are a lot
of young women who have made the
decision this is what i was struggling
with i had so many friends and family
members who have made the decision to
have an abortion
um and for me to then say that they you
murdered your baby you're a horrible
human being you're irredeemable
um it would be not it would have been
inauthentic and that's why i wasn't
ready to make that leap
um but instead you know i had remarkable
conversation with a woman um and who is
strongly pro-life and had three
abortions
and she said that she had her her come
to god moment where she realized that
she was doing this thing and she was
having these abortions because she was a
part of a society that told her
it was a compass cells right so you're
forgetting that you have these young
girls who are
they don't want to murder their
offspring right but they're growing up
in a society that is mocking
making abortion seem like it's a really
easy process if you go in you're gonna
be fine to clump the selves you have the
girls now doing the tick tock videos
making fun of like
you know how easy it is to get an
abortion you've got miley cyrus and her
abortion cake with her tongue out half
naked
you've got michelle williams on on stage
uh i think it's michelle williams on
stage
accepting an award and and giving a
speech about how happy she is she killed
her kid and she's holding a trophy
well this is what's raising your kids
culture right and so
how can you fault a young girl who goes
in and makes decision at 19 years old to
remove a clump of cells
yeah and then tell her she's
irredeemable and that's just a baby
killer that's not that's not creating
room in the conservative movement what
you can say instead
is that you know what you may have made
that mistake
that mistake when you were young you may
have done something when you were young
because you thought
you hadn't evolved and you thought that
you were making the right decision and
the best decision based on societal
pressure which tells you
when you're a young girl your whole life
is going to be ruined if you're not
married you don't have all of your
finances figured out and you have a kid
that's what you kind of learn in school
and this is the responsible decision
to get an abortion um but you can change
your mind um and you can actually be
one of the loudest voices for pro-life
it actually it holds more weight
if you're somebody that's converted away
from it and similar to me being a person
that was a liberal and converted away
from it it actually holds more weight
so what if you actually don't go that
far and you're still say more
where i would say where to me first
trimester do i believe it's a life yes
because that clump of cells you're
talking about
if we found it on the moon everybody
would say it's life right so like
i'm not playing the life game in any way
but do you think there is room for
for people that would say first
trimester or a couple weeks
or so you know some version of that we
don't have to give an exact number
um in in the conservative movement that
they don't view it as necessarily wrong
but just like an awful choice to make
or or that they worry about whatever the
the health defects are or health to the
mother or the rest of it
right so i think i think first and
foremost the most important thing that
you're doing is you're acknowledging
it's a life
that already makes things so much better
like if the left acknowledged it was a
life and taught
that it was a life abortions would
decrease no one would even be arguing
about it
in in congress anywhere because
abortions would magically decrease the
number that it was like not even a
debate right because people would
suddenly realize the baby and i'm making
it a heavier decision
because it is a baby that i'm going and
determining a pregnancy
there's a real living thing inside of me
um so the education to me is
is 90 of the battle the second point in
talking about people who abort because
they have a special needs child
um it would be really crazy to say to
people
um who were have responsibly planned you
know planned to have a child and
you know have saved up their money and
everything the right way and they find
out that their child
um is going to require much more money
much more time
um to say to people like no no matter
what you have to have this is this is
this is now
what you have to do if this is what god
gave you um would you like to think that
in every scenario people
say you know what this is what god gave
this is the you know the burden that god
gave me or i don't mean to call a child
of burden but like this is
um i guess a a a test or a
a struggle that god is putting my family
through for a reason and when people do
that it's incredible
um and and it's beautiful but to ex to
expect
rather that every single person is going
to do that to have the means to do that
especially when
i know a person who has a severely um
challenged child physically and mentally
aside from the financial burden
and and not being able to afford
anything in the stress and breaking down
people's relationships and things of
that nature
their biggest fear is that when they're
done taking care of their child no one
else will
that their child is going to a system um
and and to to
tell a parent to just accept that
reality that when you die because you
are going to die first
um that your child who is you know in a
wheelchair can't help themselves can't
can't feed themselves they can't do
anything um it is just supposed to
i guess be given uh to government and
hope that other people take care of them
is something
a burden that parents should just say
okay and give no thought to
i don't think that's realistic well and
by the way conservatives don't want
those programs too do you so if
if you were to allow people to have
certain abortions up to a certain point
or or tell no if you were to tell people
that they can't have abortions at all do
you think the state then has a
responsibility
to take care of more of those children
um you know what that's
cause that's a tough one for
conservatives right that's a tough one
do they have a responsibility well if
if it became a law if abortion if roe v
wade was flipped and all of the states
suddenly said abortion is illegal period
now people start having abortions and
first off we know like
the uncomfortable facts about this are
the people of a certain economic level
will still get abortions
in a safe manner there will be ways will
some people that aren't
economically able to do it do it in back
alleys and the hangars and all the
horrible stories
of course so you create this weird
economic thing also but if the state was
to say
no more abortions period does the state
then have a responsibility
i guess from a conservative perspective
to help these people
um well before i guess the fact that i
don't know that i've ever heard the
right a good answer
i think well the good i think the good
answer is already doing that uh maybe
the state is already when you're talking
about
what having a child is going to be a
financial burden right now i'm talking
about healthy children this is what i
really disagree like the healthy child
people are just like inconvenient throw
it away inconvenient throw it away
i mean look at the welfare system right
now and the various people that we
support and take care of and all these
different things so pretending that this
is going to be like
you know one more kid that gets a
welfare check and which i'm against by
the way i don't think you should be
raising people's children and paying for
these things and
the economic argument here is that when
the government actually stops taking all
of our
our money and giving it to all these
various programs it's been proven that
people give more people are more
inclined to do charity uh who gives more
to
to autistic causes than people that have
autistic children right
um people uh who whose parents have
suffered or died from alzheimer's the
ones that are most inclined to get to
alzheimer's research
i think that we've gotten into a place
in society where we we don't realize how
charitable people are
when they're not being robbed blindly by
the government um so
i'd like to think that as a community
people would want to take care of one
another especially people that have
lived through those situations before
they'll be more inclined to take care of
one another
but that's a that's a way bigger
question that requires more thought of
like
if you start forcing people to have
special needs you know children if
in if they were going to abort it
because not even special needs children
if
if someone just wanted to have an
abortion and you and the state said you
can't
and then they force that person to bring
the baby to term
what is the state's responsibility so
it's not it could be someone typically
you have children that grew up in group
homes
from that yeah that gives you so it's
happening already yeah it's already
happening yeah that's already that's
already built into the system because
there are some tons of people who
uh just morally don't want to have a
don't have abortions there are tons of
children that make
young girls who make that decision um
and their stories just not covered i
knew a girl who i worked with when i was
interning at vogue
um and uh she had already had a child
and she gave it up for adoption
um because she morally as a christian
did not believe in having
an abortion a beautiful little girl she
has relationship with her
um and she just was not ready to be a
mother um i actually think that
one of the biggest things that we need
to start fixing and addressing um is our
adoption
adoption system uh if you talk to any
parent that wants to adopt the child
it's like impossible
it's it it's like they can't they gotta
jump through ten thousand different
hoops by the time you thought you were
gonna have a baby now you've got a
ten-year-old because it took ten years
to go through the paperwork to be able
to adopt a child um so that would be i i
think an area of interest for me is
looking at what is the system if you
want to adopt a child and why
is it so complicated when we know that
there are tons of people that are having
children
healthy children that necessarily don't
know if they want to take care of them
what do you say to all the people that
are like oh yeah it sounds right you
should just stop all the programs and
stop the food stamps and stop the
government assistance and the subsidized
housing and section seven and blah blah
blah
yeah it sounds right you should just
stop it but but you rip that band-aid
off and then all hell breaks loose
we've talked about this a little bit
before because that's where i always see
people say ah
she just doesn't get it you know these
people are going to suddenly be all out
on the streets at once
i'm so against the welfare system i mean
i'm i'm
fully against the welfare system there's
nothing but hindered people
we've learned the lesson over and over
again if you incentivize people to do
nothing they will do nothing
um and that is exactly what the welfare
system does um it needs to be revamped
um it needs to be corrected i mean rip
it off like a band-aid
probably the best because people know
it's nothing nothing's there to support
them they're gonna figure it out that is
that is uh human nature right if you if
you know that it's not gonna a check is
not gonna come you're gonna figure out
how you're gonna eat
right i've heard people say well over a
course of a year you could slowly
keep reducing benefits but i suspect
that most people
just because it's human nature it has
nothing to do with skin color or
anything else
will still keep the same habits thinking
that at the end
it will start coming back again because
that's what the government always does
you know what i mean something yeah i
think if you slowly take it away that
people actually won't change their
habits really
no i think yeah i think they would and i
say this to somebody who i was actually
giving you
i was giving you the argument for rip it
off because it almost seems like the
shock at all
is almost the only way to do it yeah i
guess that was misunderstanding what you
were saying there because what i was
saying is that if you said to people
when they went on welfare you only got
it for one year
and that's it it's over they would have
in their head that timeline i got one
year i got a little bit of playroom and
i got to get off of welfare yeah the
problem is that it's perpetual
well that's what i mean it's almost like
it's gone on for so long that they
wouldn't even believe the government
would ever stop it so like you get the
paper
and the paper says well guys starting
today you know we've been doing this for
12 years but
every month we're cutting you know 10
percent until it's gone
right they'd just be like nah it's not
happening right and then most likely the
government caves because people will get
onto
politicians get on tv and that you see
what they're doing to these mean people
they're doing to these people it's the
mean republicans and
yeah it's got to be something that
someone does in their second term
sorry nothing you can do here it's just
happening but yeah there definitely
needs to be um
just a complete revision of the welfare
system as it is and i'm not saying that
there aren't some people that actually
have legitimate claims to help this as
i'm saying that they're
maybe there's not some people that have
legitimate claims needing an abortion
for medical emergencies and things of
those nature
but when it becomes the norm the the
overwhelming majority of people are
taking advantage and making horrible
decisions and placing a burden
on people like me and you who get up and
have to work every single day and
somehow have to support their lifestyles
of oh every time i get uh i have another
baby i get another check
that's incentivizing bad behavior i'm
just gonna keep having babies knowing i
can't afford them that's the whole
reason i'm on welfare in the first place
but
knowing that the government will give me
more and more money it's just it's just
honestly it's just human behavior
doesn't also strike you as like a sort
of very
dim and depressing view of what humans
are that unless the government forces us
to do things we'll never do anything
good for people
you know what i mean like there are
charities that i give to that i don't
run around screaming about or
i try to do some good things in my life
and treat my employees right the rest of
it
because i believe that it's on you
versus like these people that think if
you
if we don't demand that the state does
everything
no one will do anything good you're
actually saying much more about yourself
right than you're saying about people in
general right and they're wrong i mean
you can literally look at when when the
taxes are lower americans give more when
taxes are higher americans give less and
that's because they're having their own
money taken away from them
um so if they can think that all they
want but they're they're fundamentally
wrong
and i don't think that the majority of
them even think that especially not the
leaders and the politicians i think that
you just especially
on the socialist side of the argument
and
the bernie sanders and the aocs i think
they genuinely just want power for
themselves and the best people to make a
plea for power or people that are
impoverished and don't have that
self-confidence to believe in themselves
to go to them and say your life is not
your fault you know it makes them feel
better
that's right it's not my fault it's not
my fault that i had five kids out of
wedlock
um it also makes them such heroes right
i mean aoc is such a hero bernie is such
a hero he can help all these people
right
never accomplished anything but they
help all those people and they get
behind them and it's just easy votes for
them because people
at the end of the day are lazy if you
tell them they don't have to do anything
and they don't want to do anything
they're not
going to do anything so it's an easy
political strategy
um but i think what i try to tell people
is that
if you just wait right if you if you
just
go through the hard work and yes it's
not going to be easy because life is not
easy
and we're all struggling and and you can
have a bad day tomorrow even in the
midst of having
a great year but if you just wait and
and and you
put a little bit in and a little bit
more in and you do this every day day in
and day out
that feeling that you get when you
accomplish something the feeling that i
have right now sitting across from you
knowing that
i now run two businesses by myself um
and i started my life as a girl in a
a roach infested apartment um you
wouldn't trade that feeling for the
world there's
the government can't do that for you
that feeling of accomplishment and
that's what i think
um is being taken away from individuals
knowing how good it feels when you get
to the finish line
ah that's good we should end there but
we're not ending that but that was that
was the right ending
let's just do a couple more of the of
those sort of what the conservatives can
do to maybe be a little more open that
we we talked about on your show
um so one of them was marijuana so i
told you
my feeling is that marijuana should be
legal i don't care if the states do it
i'd prefer not
the federal government to do it because
i think it should be a states rights
issue and if
colorado passes it and you know you
don't like it then you can move
somewhere else and if you move somewhere
else and they don't
have it and you want it and move to
colorado and the rest of it that's how i
like the
american experiment to work most
conservatives
um are pretty much against legalizing
marijuana at either level
excuse me and they they sort of take
this
odd approach because you would think
that they would want the government
out of people's lives how do you uh
sort of arbitrage that first and
foremost there seems to be a disconnect
with
a lot of conservatives about the effects
of marijuana i know like
i've spoken to some people who have
never spoken marijuana smoking
smoked marijuana in their life and i'm
actually i'm thinking of someone i used
to date who had never smoked
marijuana in his life and what was
really interesting about it is that
he had it in the same categories like
heroin like i was i was just impressed
with how wrong he was about what people
do
what you know when they smoke a joint
like he thinks i don't know maybe it's
like a
methamphetamine they get up they go
rubble shoot it shoot a gas station rob
people
and the truth is is that um it makes
people
in my opinion impotent uh they sit on
couches they they
they want to eat a bunch they're
laughing they watch movies they're
definitely not going out and and
and committing crimes and and things of
that nature um i think the conservative
argument is that it's a gateway drug
i think everybody they love that and i
just where i have but then it's like
well alcohol is a gay
that's that's what i was going to get at
so i had this um this debate with rick
santorum
actually he was sitting next to me and
he was talking about the marijuana thing
and i actually didn't really have a
stance on it i just like to engage my
brain
um and debate people when i think that
they have something that's fundamentally
missing in their argument and
he was drinking a glass of wine and
saying that marijuana should permanently
be banned because of its bad effects and
i said well how do you reconcile that
with you drinking wine
and you know i go years in and out of
not drinking alcohol i'm not drinking
alcohol this year didn't drink alcohol
when you met me
um and uh you had one good year in there
though my wedding yeah
you can't you can't we had a good time
we had a good time you can't not drink
when you're getting married
uh because everybody gives you alcohol
it's the only gift you get for a whole
year until you get married
um but so i'm saying that i'm seeing him
drink this glass of wine
and i'm wondering how he's reconciling
it and he and he says oh well this is
different and i will tell me how it's
different
well alcohol it's different for me if
i'm drinking alcohol in my house and i'm
like well that's exactly their argument
for for
smoking pot and i said actually if you
want to talk about having a worse impact
on society alcohol causes way more
deaths
people get drunk they go home they beat
their wives they party they make
mistakes you know they
it is the gateway car accident car
accidents the car accident happened from
duis uh which is higher than by the way
uh people that are killed by guns every
year look at the deaths by mortar
vehicles nobody's talking about taking
people's cars away we don't
have to give in our cars yeah um but uh
so i said that to him
and and i think he was starting to see i
was like if you're gonna make that
argument you need to make the argument
more soundly
um because you either are a person that
believes that there should be
you should have seen from everything and
that society is just better off without
everything
or if you're saying that people have
should have the you know the right the
personal right to
engage in drinking and getting blacked
out drunk at bars so long as they don't
drive themselves home
then you're going to have a hard time
arguing that people shouldn't have the
same right when it comes to pot right
and it's funny
because for someone like me it's like
well
i see the conservative perspective is
conservatives really want to do what
they think
in the long term over generations is
good for a sound and secure and safe
society i'm not saying marijuana is for
it or against it i mean
i've told you i smoke weed maybe once a
week i watch the simpsons at 11 o'clock
and i pass that on the couch
i don't hurt anybody i have never robbed
a bank on weed and i probably do eat too
much popcorn
on weed that would be like the one thing
you know um
but so i understand their argument of
like but if you just
if you just tell people that this is
okay then they'll go oh something else
is okay or this is okay but
you can't stop human nature and for the
same people that don't want to legislate
a lot of stuff i think it's just a
dangerous
yeah i don't i don't smoke pot and and i
say to people i would recommend people
not not smoking pog because it just
i think it kills ambition like some
people are different you know people
like you are like i can smoke and go to
bed and
get up and do what i have the next day
but i think overwhelmingly it kills
ambition
now as a free market capitalist i'm fine
with that because i'll crush the
competition
that's the answer yeah that's good crush
the competition so if you want to smoke
your pot and stay in bed i'm gonna go
run the world
um but yeah i think i think it's hard i
think it's really tricky and i
i i i understand that argument of like
well then they'll be looking for the
next thing they'll be looking for the
next thing once you say that's okay
and and that's true but i just don't see
i don't see how i can make a sound
argument when
people are okay with drinking alcohol so
you would basically kick it to the
states
which is sort of where it's actually the
other argument where i i said to him and
by the way i was just saying this for
the sake of arguing you know because i
just like to debate ideas
i said do you think that legislating did
it stop people from smoking pot
it didn't actually didn't say i i don't
know any person that i went to college
that did not smoke pot
so when it was illegal it wasn't like
people weren't doing it right and the
funny part is now i don't know if
there's there must be some studies on
this but now that it's legal by states
like i doubt
many more people are smoking weed
because it suddenly got legal right
because it was so ubiquitous everywhere
you can get it anywhere so i don't think
suddenly somebody was like well it's
legal i'm gonna smoke
pot that's right nobody no everyone that
i knew was smoking pot before it and by
the way most of them ended up stopping
at a certain age and because it became
legal didn't make them go oh well now
i'm going to go out and do it
um so it's it's like you know when i
first drank i wasn't i wasn't 21 years
old
you know what i'm saying sorry the
legality of it being 21 years old
yeah that'll come back to haunt me when
they dig this up 30 years from now
the legality of it said the law saying
that i can't drink until
21 did nothing to stop me from drinking
well before i was 21.
i mean i drank in high school i drank
when i was 15 years old 14 15 years old
literally um
so it was the first time that i got
drunk and i continued to drink
somebody's
older brother or sister would buy us a
pack of beer and do all that nature so
the idea
that what's bad about that concept is
the idea that like if suddenly it
becomes legal
suddenly people will get in line um it's
it's just a it's a faulty argument
because we already know that people
don't follow the laws
george carlin has a funny line on pot
which is like he's like most drugs you
do them and you want more and more and
more
pot like you're like smoking it one day
you're like okay i've had enough of that
right
yeah that's pretty much it on that okay
so uh so we talked abortion we talked
uh marijuana the other one we talked
about was sort of a carving a space for
secular conservatives and i'm really
curious about this space
because i've had have you have you
talked to heather mcdonald on your show
yet from the manhattan institute
she's a great free market capitalist
yeah i know and thinkers
a lot of great work on the diversity
delusion yeah so you should definitely
talk to her i'll connect you guys and
she's wonderful
she is a secular conservative she's been
an atheist or an agnostic her entire
life she said she was never a believer
she was
brought up in a totally secular home and
she thinks that there's a strong
secular argument for conservatism most
conservatives
don't really think that i would love to
see and you know i've had my own sort of
spiritual awakening where i
i am a believer and i certainly believe
for a society to organize more than
anything else it has to have
some underlying set of set of beliefs um
and our founders talked about god-given
rights and the rest of it
do you think there is space for that
because i feel like this one makes a lot
of
conservatives nervous like that they
would let them in these godless people
or something and that they're gonna
somehow un rattle the whole thing
yeah i definitely don't think they're
going to rattle anything i think
actually when you once you invite people
into the conservative movement they'll
naturally
um i think they'll naturally tread
towards
spiritualism and here's why um you
you can't say that you believe in
western civilization without
acknowledging that there would be no
western civilization without
judeo-christian beliefs uh we are what
judeo-christian beliefs is what brought
the world forward
any studying of of western society
brings you right back to
um you know the the early greek miracle
and and what what was the greek miracle
it was an understanding a move away
from the the tribalism that naturally
followed a polytheistic worldview
right so when when the world used to
believe in polytheism when everybody
thought there was a rain god and the sun
god
and uh god for your illness whatever it
was they
were naturally more tribal because
they'd sacrificed i'm gonna kill 26 kids
to sacrifice to the rain god today
and there was no sense there was no
sense of reason there was no morality
because this everything was all
crikey the rain god must be pissed off
right you know um i must sacrifice this
goat to the to the rain god
or oh crikey our crops are are um
are dried out i must sacrifice this and
there was no thought process and then
the greek miracle happened
um you know this concept of freedom
where people started to think more and
philosophize
and we had those early philosophers uh
you know plato aristotle socrates who
started saying what if there's just one
what if it's
it's one god and what if my actions
actually matter what if morality matters
it was that that was the beginning that
was the breakthrough where we started
they started to really start to believe
in freedom
right and they developed this this
monotheistic worldview and it reshaped
everything it is literally the beginning
of western society that happened with
that greek miracle
um and and then what what then
transpired beyond that
um was once they started to realize that
wow like
maybe there there is a higher power and
maybe my actions do matter
they naturally started to say wow then
that means we have to question
everything that we've ever known that
was immoral and they eventually got to
the concept of slavery which was done
everywhere in the world
until they had started started thinking
about when she started the the christian
people
led the world in ending slavery because
they said there is no longer
there there cannot be a moral ground for
slavery it matters my actions matter
and that was when we saw slavery get
abolished led first by
the french colonies i think uh french
colonies were first followed by britain
followed by america
you know the old white men the terrible
horrible white men they led the world in
ending slavery
um and that was that was the reason why
right so if you
if you fundamentally understand why the
west is the best
why the west is great how the west
became the west um then you do know that
you can't untether that from
judeo-christian belief
um so i think that it's it's you invite
them in
that you can be atheistic and you can be
conservative right but if you really
understand
what you're trying to conserve right
when you get you start doing the work
which i had to do which is like i know
that i'm conservative
what is conservatism what am i working
to conserve what i'm working to conserve
is western society
what i'm working to conserve is the idea
of freedom what i'm working to conserve
is that early greek miracle that
happened and i can't untether that from
judea christian belief man you're
getting good at this okay
a little bit of work you know you gotta
you gotta you gotta read some books and
uh
and uh really not just ask yourself what
you believe but ask what ask yourself
why you believe it
all right so speaking of books i don't
have a copy of black out here
because the galleys have not arrived yet
they have not arrived the galleys are on
the way
i know that a lot of what we discussed
here obviously is what blackout
is about um but what what maybe did i
miss
or should we should we hit on or you
know so blackout for me it was i really
wanted to
first and foremost lay out my personal
story there's been a lot of conjecture
about where i came from how i became
conservative is she a fraudulent
conservative and
all of that craziness because people
don't realize that i just was a
political if anything else
to be clear you're not some sort of
secret agent no remember you
really have been there through all of
this i've been there i mean
the youtubers like digesting my entire
life saying like
she must be a plant like i mean a
sorrow's plan i'm like i've never even
voted
like i literally prior to getting
getting into things i had i
genuinely just was not politically
inclined um and i just thought i had to
be a democrat and thought i had to be a
liberal and
you know looking in the retrospect i
realized how foolish that is um
you know that i didn't realize that
everything was really that everything
that bad happened in my life was really
routed to
bad policies and bad politicians but i
wanted to first lay out just my personal
story um you know the subtitle of the
book is how black america can make its
second
escape from the democrat plantations and
i do believe
i say this all the time people get upset
that black americans are still enslaved
today
that the left just got smarter and they
realize that you you can enslave people
um their bodies you can't have black
black americans on the plantation
anymore but you can still have black
americans doing all the work for you
and reaping no benefit and that is a
structure that we see today between
black america and the democratic party
we are doing all the work we get we
carry them over the finish line
and we benefit not in one single way
and so i really kind of lay out that
argument um and then talk about
what slave life was really like the
breakdown of family why it was necessary
for families to be broken down
uh to trade constantly be trading um
slaves from one plantation to the nut to
the next they could they could have no
feelings for one another
um at frederick douglass uh in his
autobiography
the first couple of pages and he starts
talking about his life as a slave
uh he talks about the fact when his
mother died he felt nothing
when his sisters were treated he felt
nothing he had no sense of kinship no no
familial love
for his own blood that was necessary to
the institution of slavery we still have
that kinship and that relationship and
that community still broken down
all of these years later later despite
the reconstruction era post slavery
uh which we saw black american families
getting back together we were we were
doing something
um it's all been wiped out at a higher
rate by the way until about
72 or so yeah in the 1950s uh black
americans were outpacing whites in terms
of economic growth
um and then immediately following you
know the night the 1960s and the great
society act
um and the systemic oppression which
started via the welfare system
everything started falling apart
um and uh reading another another topic
talking going back to slavery uh black
americans it was illegal for black
americans to learn how to read
in fact it was so illegal that if you
were a white person you were taught
and you were and you were caught
teaching you're slave to read you would
be found guilty too it was a serious sin
the reason for that is uh because they
didn't want black people being educated
because an educated mind can't be
enslaved
well what's changed look at the
illiteracy rates in black america today
look at baltimore look at the inner
cities look at where in california
california
70 percent of black boys could not pass
a basic literacy exam
nobody is talking about that you have
politicians that are standing on stage
saying that all they care about is black
americans they're not talking about
everything that is harming black
americans today everything that is
recreating
the very same plantations that we came
from did you catch that brilliant line
that bernie had in one of the debates
which is he wants he's not only so
pro-marijuana that he wants it to be
legal
but he also wants to have uh black
community blacks
black business owners owning black
marijuana shops
in black communities i did not catch
that and again i say this i say this as
someone that's pro
legalizing but like we're going to
incentivize black people to own
black marijuana right shops in black
communities that
that right and that's and that's why i
don't celebrate by the way why i am
conservative on the marijuana front is
because when you talk about
where this is happening chicago i think
just passed you know marijuana laws
it is to me i i i know it's going to
lead to more dysfunction
um you know amongst black america first
and foremost because that's how it
always is
you know it's it's what is it about
progressive policies that always leads
to progressive results for the black
community
first and foremost and um so i i
am loathe uh to to be smart enough to
see the debate between
uh alcohol and marijuana so that i can't
firmly study
marijuana but i have a thinking brain
and i just don't see how conservatives
can make a sound argument against it at
the moment
what else has to happen for the black
community to break
i'm gonna guess although i don't have
the book yet that at the end you're
gonna you either make some predictions
or you
tell people what tools they need to
really break out of this
yeah you know it's it's not even about
making predictions and i have my own
personal predictions but i definitely am
not doing that in the book i'm giving
black americans a guide i'm giving
giving black americans an option uh the
same option uh that i saw before me
when i started waking up and i'm having
this conversation with you
um you can you can have the option to
accept this victim narrative right you
can have the option to say
i accept this diagnosis of cancer even
though i feel fine walk fine and have
been living fine my entire life
i accept that it's terminal illness and
i'm gonna live like i'm gonna die
any moment or or you can you can develop
a different perspective and you can
develop a victor mentality as i say
forget the victim mentality develop a
victor mentality
look back at your ancestors look back at
your your grandparents look back at what
they did what they lived through the
seas that they planted that you can
afford to be in the circumstance that
you are in today
if you are a black american and you are
breathing in the united states today
you are the luckiest among the luckiest
of black people that have ever lived
anywhere on the face of the planet that
is an incredible statement
all of human history the luckiest black
people that have ever lived on the face
of the human planet are the ones that
are living and breathing
in america today okay if you understand
that
and you should understand it by simply
saying where would you like to live in
africa
for all that that that that hoopla about
they took us from africa find me a a
black american that will tell you they
want to move back to africa i will
listen right now or europe i'll book the
flights for them
right for any person that says we were
stolen from our ancestors i can of
course and pledging
that i will book the flights if you
renounce your u.s citizenship for you to
go live back in africa you want you want
to cap this at maybe
10 people just in case people are
punking there's none we did this we did
the same craziness
i hate america everyone offered their
money in flights i think you might have
died
nobody took nobody took the bait right
because they know
america is the greatest place they could
possibly live um and
you know what if someone takes you up on
this i'll guarantee one one first class
upgrade
that's amazing i will do that there we
go right here i will first class
upgrades
go to america but you have to renounce
your citizenship to america
and move to africa that's really what
you want to do um and
and look you look at africa today
um this whole concept that we were taken
and we were kings and queens like this
weird myth like this disney story
this disney fairy tale that we were all
running around kings and queens and
uh enjoying the crops and and the
fertile land and all ever
all that we had and then evil white men
came with their guns
well you're telling me zamanda is not a
place
this is this is really what the story
has come down to
when in fact um we were sold by our own
ancestors
we were already living in terrible
situations we were already slaves we
were already being enslaved
um we we were enslaved first by the
arabs the heirs were the first to
enslave africans
um and we were sold for things as
meaningless talk about how
how tribal their society was we were
sold for gin
we were sold for mirrors imagine africa
look a mirror oh i'll take tony of my
strongest men
thanks for the mirror it takes 20 of my
strongest men these are the reasons that
we were sold this is how tribal and how
backwards
um their society was um take ownership
of that take ownership of the fact that
when you look at human history
and you look at all the horrible things
that have happened nobody's guiltless
least of all people that are in africa
because today the slave trade still goes
on the slave trade still goes on in the
sub-saharan region
the very same region that black
americans descend from they are still
being enslaved
they're in a miss of a nasty civil war
there's child slavery there's child
there there's child labor uh there's
people that are being sold to
to uh sex rings and this is the
situation of
child slaves in in ghana today that are
working along lake valta
um uh something like 30 000 of them cnn
actually did a report on it last year
you know
uh because they one of them had escaped
and he talked about how they would be
beat
and he said he was beat so bad that he
wished that he was never born um if
they were caught trying to eat the food
this still goes on in that place that
you keep glorifying that you keep
pretending
that the worst that ever happened was
that our ancestors were brought to
america
um by and large you can look back on
that and realize um
and while certainly it wasn't in the
circumstance back then
it is today that it was a blessing in
the retrospect it was a blessing that we
got out
of africa and that we are we are in
america today which is why so many of
africans
are trying to emigrate to america today
on that note candace owens i'm so proud
of you like on the professional level
i'm just proud of you but on a personal
level like it's just
like i know you like i know you are the
real deal
and you have relentlessly lived up to
everything that you have said
and you're just you're just gonna keep
going and it's just uh
well i thank you and i really do mean
this like uh
being on your show the first time i'm so
happy that it was your show that i sat
down across from first
because you didn't push me you didn't
say you need to know everything you have
a stance on everything candace
you just accepted that i was
authentically saying i want to learn
right and um i've done that and i've
tried to remain authentic and it's
thanks to people like you
that create a space like you were
talking about for people to be able to
learn
uh to be able to grow and to not feel
like they need to be tribal and their
political
beliefs i i feel that i've been able to
uh to grow and feel
confident in what i actually do believe
in today
i'll go with that i know you follow her
already but it's
real candace oh on twitter thanks for
watching
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell